he made a spur-of-the-moment decision to
jump on a bus
to new york now i don't know where the
bus is coming from i'm guessing it's
from the dc area
um but i don't know where he was living
at the time so this could have been like
from california to new york like you
know
in one of the movies i say hopped on a
spur the spur of the moment hopped on a
bus to go to the
us premiere of the final harry potter
movie
and camped out overnight in line um
that's commitment but he was rewarded
for that commitment because he met both
rupert grint and daniel radcliffe so
let's applaud him for his um dogmatic
desire to see harry potter and
welcome tyler to the stage
uh hi everyone uh thanks uh for the
introduction jared uh my name is tyler
morganwall and i'm a researcher at the
institute for defense analysis here in
washington dc
i took the bus from baltimore so it
wasn't california but you know
it was still uh it was still a fun time
um so uh i'm the author of uh the ray
shader package
a package that allows you to generate
beautiful maps and 3d data
visualizations in r
um so it's an incredibly exciting time
to be working with spatial data and r
because the ecosystem for spatial data
has evolved immensely in the past few
years
uh so no longer is mapping purely the
domain of experienced cartographers
and closed source gis software suites uh
nowadays you can create maps with just a
basic knowledge of r and a few lines of
code so in this talk
i'm going to be showing how you can use
ray shader along with
free and open data sets to create
engaging 3d visualizations entirely in r
using no outside software so i'm going
to show you where these types of
visualizations fall in your database
toolbox
and how you can use them to bring
attention to your projects and analyses
and win the hearts and minds of your
audience
so first things first what is ratiater
uh
ray shader is a package for 2d and 3d
data visualization in
r specifically ray shader uses a
technique called ray tracing
to realistically simulate how light
falls on landscapes and 3d surfaces
on the left you can see how ray shader
calculates uh the shadows cast by
buildings in philadelphia
as the day progresses uh using lidar
data from the city along with the sun
package to calculate the position of the
sun and the sky
ray shader can take these 2d maps and
project them
into 3d as we see on the right
ratiator also includes functions to
apply post-processing effects to enhance
these 3d maps
so here i've added a depth of field
effect
which blurs areas far away from the
focal point and a camera vignetting
effect to add all subtle darkening by
the edges
like you get in a high-end camera
so some people say that visualizing
spatial data isn't special
that you just use the same techniques
you use when you visualize non-spatial
data and any distinction between the
field of cartography
and the field of data vis is more of a
historical artifact
but i think there is indeed something
special about working with spatial data
so normal data visualizations live in an
abstract world of well-defined axes
uh usually situated in a pristine blank
void
uh spatial data on the other hand exists
in our world
uh you just can't place an x and y axis
down dump your data in and expect it to
stand on its own
so these data here on the right are the
major highways around monterey bay
california
but there's no way you would know that
just from looking at the road data
itself
you actually have to build the world
that the data lives in
so people can contextualize and
interpret those data points
so spatial data visualization actually
combines two distinct
fields cartography which builds the map
on which the data lives and what we
consider to be traditional data
visualization
uh lines uh points polygons etc
so ratiator has tools to support both of
these fields
uh it provides functions that allows you
to build the underlying map
and also to add data onto that map
so ray shader does all of this with a
straightforward pipeable interface
where you use elevation data to generate
shadows and maps
so here the hobart object at the top of
the chain is just an r matrix
a 2d array of elevation values at every
point um to the right i've plotted the
data with base r's
image function uh with terrain colors
which in my opinion doesn't really
represent the terrain in a very
understandable way so we can produce we
can use radiator to produce something
much nicer
um we can first generate a base color
layer with the sphere shade function in
radiator
which colors in the map using the angle
and slope of the terrain
um so we can already see how this is uh
far better than the pure height to color
mapping
because what were once blobs of colors
are now much more obviously
mountains and valleys um i can add a
water layer with the radiator function
detect water which detects large
contiguous flat areas
on the elevation matrix and colors them
in i can add some realistic shadows with
the ray shade function
um i can add another layer of shadows to
darken the valleys with uh ambi
uh the ambient shade function um
which all in all generates a very nicely
2d map
entirely from an r matrix and just a
couple lines of code
um so this is nice but the real magic
with radiator is how easy it is to
transform this map
into 3d so we simply just take this
output
and pass it along to the plot3d function
along with the original matrix of height
values
so this function generates the 3d mesh
represented
by the hobart matrix and paints the
surface of it
with the output of everything above so
you can generate either still snapshots
of the map with the render snapshot
function
or call the render movie function to
generate a spinning 3d gif like this
now everything in radiator is
customizable uh that's the cartography
part of the package
um changing the color palette is
incredibly simple uh there are seven
built-in palettes but you can create
your own with the create texture
function
as well as customize the watercolor
when you create your 3d plot you can
either explore it interactively by
dragging the 3d model around
or control the camera programmatically
with the render camera function
so this is useful if you want to create
a complex animation where the camera
zooms
in and around different views of your
data set
and this is also where working with 3d
models in a programming language
shines so you can program an entire
animation in a single for loop
like you would script any other
repetitive task
so on the right i've plotted the camera
angles phi and theta
along with a rendering of a diagram of
the scene
and a view from the camera itself so the
code showing how i generated this camera
view is on the left
and which shows how complex animations
don't necessarily require
complex code
now our planet's climate is currently
going through an enormous transitory
period
and due to the scale of this problem
many of us who work in government and in
the public sector
are often in the best position to tackle
the problem of climate change
however in order to have buy-in from the
public
we need to have the proper tools to
communicate these issues
to decision makers in an engaging and
intuitive way
one of my main goals with ray shader was
to make a dead symbol
to make beautiful informative
visualizations at this critical
interface
of land and water so here all a user has
to do to visualize a change in coastline
is to set the depth the water uh water
level in plot3d
or actually just call the function
render water so ray shader handles all
the 3d rendering and slicing
and you can customize the color and
opacity of the water
if you aren't just interested in a map
but rather are interested in data
overlaid
on the map ratio also has the ability to
add other types of spatial data
so here i have generated some fake bird
tracking
data and overlaid it in 3d on a map of
monterey bay
so i can change it to either be
displayed as a continuous path
with the render path function or as
individual data points with render
points
uh here these data are simply lat long
altitude values
passed in as individual numeric vectors
this interface of passing xyz data is
fine if you're passing
in small data sets but most spatial data
in r comes packaged
in spatial data formats so r has a vast
ecosystem of packages to work with
spatial data
but one of the most popular and fastest
growing in the community is the simple
features package
sf so simple features are a standardized
way to encode spatial
vector data and ratio includes support
for both uh spatial line and spatial
polygon overlays
uh so all you have to do to pass in the
simple features object
uh is pass it into the corresponding
ratio function generate line overlay or
generate
uh polygon overlay and it will add it
directly to the surface of the map
so you can also specify column in the s
object at map to color
like an aesthetic function in ggplot so
to the left i've again plotted the major
highways around monterey bay but this
time in 3d
and to the right i've plotted the
buildings in seattle
where the polygon is colored by the
height of the building itself
um so well a flat overlays are nice
uh ray shader goes one step further and
allows you to integrate fully
3d data from sf with the render path and
render polygons functions
so adding 3d data to both of these
scenes is a simple
one-liner performed by passing in the
simple features object
into the corresponding function and
specifying which variable maps to the
third dimension
um so to the left i've plotted the
trails in zion national park
and to the right i've again plotted the
buildings in seattle
but this time as a 3d extruded polygon
rather than as an image overlay
um so you can easily add labels to your
map using lat long coordinates
add a scale bar or even just add a
compass
to give context to your spatial data so
all of these features combine
to enable you to bring your viewers on a
cinematic tour of your data set
in a reproducible way all within a
single r
script and one of the best things about
working with spatial data
is how much of it is freely available
and easy to access
so the usgs provides massive amounts of
data on the entire us
such as gridded elevation building
footprints tree cover water and streams
water tables road and trail information
the list is endless
and usually the only thing you need to
do to access this data is to create a
free
account with the usgs um so i recommend
especially the usgs national map website
because it provides a nice point and
click interface to search for and
download multiple types of data
and you can really get a taste of what's
available just by browsing that
additionally the landsat program
provides free
up-to-date worldwide satellite worldwide
satellite imagery
so as an example earlier this year in
the spring i read a news article that
was discussing the annual poppy bloom
in the antelope valley california poppy
reserve
so the bloom had just started earlier
that week so i went to the usgs earth
explorer website
and downloaded satellite imagery that
was just taken a few days prior
and combined it with elevation data also
from the usgs to create a 3d
representation of the landscape
with this year's bloom which you can see
here on this ratiater map
so if you're working on a project that
involves some form of constantly
evolving spatial data
like let's say wildfires it's an
incredibly powerful tool to be able to
quickly generate
and automate the creation of these types
of visualizations
that represent current events especially
if you're dealing with the public
so if you've seen all this and you're
thinking well i actually don't really
work with spatial data
are there ways i can use ratiator to
plot let's say non-geographic data
the answer is yes ray shader can also
create
3d gg plots directly from a ggplot
object
so here you can map any variable that
you'd normally map to color to 3d
what's nice about using ggplot to power
these visualizations as a user
versus creating an entirely 3d plotting
a new 3d plotting interface
is that you don't have to learn anything
new you can bootstrap off of your
hard-earned pre-existing ggplot
knowledge
to produce an entirely new type of data
visualization
and this api for 3d gtg plots is
incredibly simple
so ray shader just simply takes us an
input the existing gg plots and
and then it extrudes it to 3d um which
in my opinion can lead to some pretty
awesome results
and i think it's far easier than any
other 3d database software out there
so it's simple enough where you can
actually play and experiment with your
visualization
um which as an end user i think is
really important because often you don't
really know
what you're doing ahead of time you kind
of play around with it um and with 3d
data with 3d database that can often
lead to kind of like a big
bowl of spaghetti um but uh this
provides a nice kind of
um more limited uh method
um you don't get floating points lines
or labels but you often get something
right out of the box that works really
well
so all in this uh all of this together i
think that most people would agree that
r is best in its class when it comes to
2d database
thanks to ggplot and even just the
robust uh base our plotting system
but i wanted to make sure that it kept
that title when it came to 3d database
and that meant r needed to compete with
professional 3d rendering software
i think less like a playstation 2 and
more like
something out of pixar so this required
a bit of work however since there is
nothing built into r
to support high quality 3d rendering
to support these types of visualizations
i wrote the ray render package
which is a path tracer written entirely
in r and available on the cran
for those of you who are talking
yesterday about the difficulty
about getting outside software on
government servers this
is key because while it might be a hard
sell to get it people to approve
a standalone program like blender or
many other 3d rendering software out
there if you have
r approved this package comes for free
when you create your local copy of the
crayon
so ray render is a powerful flexible and
extremely capable package for 3d
rendering
but that complexity does make it
somewhat more difficult on its own to
pick up than ray shader
however acknowledging this i've written
an extremely simple function in ray
shader
that integrates ray render and just
requires a single function called
render high quality um so this function
takes your current 3d scene
and renders it using realistic light
transport algorithms
resulting in a beautiful realistic
rendering entirely in r
and you'll see a lot of my
visualizations in this talk are made
using this interface
so in my opinion it's by far the most
accessible
way to start making 3d uh beautiful 3d
maps
you no complex software build
instructions or hour long youtube
walkthroughs required
just call a single function and get a
beautiful data vis as the output
so after all this you might be asking
yourself a question well
when should i actually use 3d plots like
these what purpose do they serve
where do they fall within my toolbox and
you're right to ask this because some
uses of 3d aren't great um the 3d pie
chart is the classic example
uh pie charts and code data and the size
of the wedge and usually the 3d adds
nothing
um generally superfluous use of 3d is to
be avoided
even if you make it look really good
and even non-superfluous 3d plots have
some downsides
um so generally data can obscure other
data that's behind it
the use of perspective can make
comparisons between data points harder
and generally you lose the ability to
pull out the exact value the z-axis is
representing
however there are some cases where the
positives do outweigh the negatives
so 3d offers some perceptual advantages
over color
color perception varies from person to
person so it's an obvious difference to
one might not be to another
and 3d can be far more engaging than a
2d plot encoding the same data
so here's an example we have two plots
that show the same data
with one plotted in a traditional 2d
color plot
and the other plotted and animated in 3d
so this is the classic jon snow cholera
data set
here visualizing the number of nearest
neighbors per infection site
now these two plots aren't
interchangeable in purpose
if you were submitting this data to a
journal you likely wouldn't use the 3d
plot
because the 3d projection makes the
exact values difficult to read
the the fact that the 3d plot is more
engaging doesn't do anything for you in
a journal
since the hook in an academic article
needs to be in the abstract not buried
in the paper
however if you are trying to communicate
these results to the public
or highlight them in a talk particularly
to audiences who might not be intimately
familiar with the data
already the 3d plot is far more useful
3d and animation is a far better hook
than a paragraph of text to you
to readers who aren't already familiar
with your topic
and ray shader provides you with the
tools to easily generate these
visualizations
directly in r so here's a real life
example
of 3d plots being used as a hook so
these animations were created by dr
robbie bishop taylor of
geoscience australia and are used to
promote their project of mapping the
entire australian continents coastline
using 30 years of landsat imagery of the
tide going in and out
so the animation on the left is a
traditional figure
that you'd see in a journal so
informative but kind of abstract and
definitely geared towards experts
as it assumes the reader is familiar
with concepts like color ramps and
contour plots
the animation on the right however was
designed for much wider consumption
it uses the research to show something
that people will be much more familiar
with
the tides going in and out represented
in a way much
closer to reality than a color map um so
this
visualization actually ended up being
featured on nasa earth
and got a lot of very good attention on
twitter when it was posted
i think the original post got like 300
likes um which was pretty good
and the 3d animation definitely helped
bring in readers uh that otherwise
wouldn't have known about the research
and the work that this government agency
in australia was doing
and finally uh the 3d toolbox provided
by rayshader rayrender
allows you to produce some truly
stunning and informative visualizations
to bring attention to your projects so
this past year i was
tracking the arctic sea ice and saw that
we were having yet another year of
record melts
so i'd seen polar ice barrel plots on
the left before
which show the arctic sea ice as time
progresses but
i had always found that they were a bit
too abstract
because it's hard to understand what a
number like 17 million kilometers
squared truly
represents um so i used the ray render
package
along with open data from the national
uh snow and ice data center
to show the actual shape that these
values corresponded to
and animated these values for the past
30 years
so this visualization ended up getting
to the front page of reddit
and people generally agreed that adding
the globes on the right
made it much more understandable which
was only possible
by the great spatial ecosystem in our
this involved uh
sf raster um the angler packages
uh just just a lot of a lot of different
packages
went together to make something like
this but it ended up being just a kind
of a short script
um and if you're actually interested in
seeing how i made this visualization i
actually have a blog post to my website
at tylermw.com
where i explain the process and include
all the code so check it out if you're
interested in the details or
you know want to produce some sort of
other global maps like this
um so here's some more resources if you
want some more information about
ratiater
uh for examples actually i recommend
going on twitter and checking out the
ratingator hashtag
um so the r community has created a lot
of fantastic uh visualizations
especially recently because
uh november is the 30 30 day mapping
challenge
um so that i saw it must have been at
least 100
um different uh visualizations made
using r and ray shader that were just
really great maybe not 100 but close to
that um the website ratio.com has all of
the documentation and lots of examples
along with a fairly extensive
walkthrough and on my github i actually
have materials available
from a master class i taught with the
pen musa program on how to make maps and
3d visualizations with ray shader
and i know there are some other talks
about using lidar data i actually go
through that
show how you can use raw lidar data to
create some maps
um you that show uh the the effect of uh
rising sea levels i think in the example
i use miami
but there's really a lot of really cool
things you can do with our um and i have
some examples of that
that's freely available um so thank you
so much for uh
analytics for inviting me to speak and
thank you for listening
thank you very much for the talk i think
we all enjoyed that
whenever tyler speaks it always gets a
lot of wows um
he does some really cool stuff for his
package and enabled so many people to do
it so thank you for that fun talk
we have a few